and that is jamison tyone who is towing
the slab into boogie down bronx tonight
you can see his numbers have rounded
into form very nicely
only 35 walks 116 strikeouts he said
throughout his career he's always
relished
because
those
grounded to velazquez
and easy out as kepler
is retired
that's the left center field
and dropping in front of gallow for a
one ounce single right off the end of
the bat
fly ball into right stanton waits
two down you know they're locked in
rudder goes
throw down is on the money
a laser from higashioka
to end the first
you can't throw a seed any more
perfectly than that
starting pitcher stats
brought to you by home furniture john
gant
who does have starting experience this
season it was in st louis he's been used
out of the bullpen
with the minnesota twins and
was impressed with his stuff his last
timeout he's
saw that fastball in the mid 90s he had
good movement on it and
he's expressed the desire to start
you can see
twins have used
13 this year and gant
number 13 lucky number 13 he hopes
that's the center
back is gordon
so the catch one away
shade them towards left center just a
little bit
sinker chopped to simmons
two
down three and two to judge
and right to polanco
and a one two three first inning for
john kent
swinging and a miss
cino down on strikes first k of the game
for jameson tyonne
very sharp very good mix of pitches
threw him a curveball and a couple of
sliders and
well located him if you're to throw a
slider that's exactly how and where you
throw it
and camp gets a strikeout
well he's pitching like a guy who wants
another start
and he he's doing exactly what he did
pitching out of the pulpit which is
throw strikes first inning 11 pitches
seven strikes but you can see the
movement even from the center field
camera which gives you some idea what it
must look like in the batter's box
and the one-two swing and a miss and
down he goes on a cutter
so here comes john gant two perfect
innings he has struck out two
so far tonight
swing and a miss
second strikeout for tyonne one down in
the third
the 2-2
tapped weakly to the left side wade
spins and fires in time and everyone
escapes the death star
unscathed we go to the bottom of the
third no score thanks to the smooth
wheeling
of tyler wade
to end this in
velasquez a switch into batting left
drives that in the air to right center
field in deep gordon on the run dives
can't make the catch hits off the wall
velazquez on his horse he's into third
with a lead off triple
well a switch hitter but i tell you one
thing
he's got a little bit of pop in that
back
you know he's not a slap hitter he
drives this to the gap and gordon makes
an excellent effort
and actually gets there right off the
edge of the glove
the diving effort from gordon
but here's the other part of the game
kid's got some wheels
this is going to be an easy triple at
this point
[Applause]
that's what you call sliding into third
with a stand-up triple he's on third
with nobody out higashiyoka at the plate
ripped fair face hit down the left field
line velazquez will score he got shioka
into second with an rbi double and the
yankees take a one-nothing lead
and here comes voight now all of a
sudden one swing in the back
could be three runs
void hits that hard fear
down the left field line into the corner
it goes higashioka will score wade being
waved around third here's the throw it's
high wade's safe boyd advances to third
it's a two-run double from the lead off
man luke voight and the yankees lead is
three-nothing
the three-two
rizzo fights that off into center
foyt tags he'll go gordon does not have
a great arm the throw will skip in late
boyd scores it's a sacrifice fly for
anthony rizzo and the yankees extend
their lead to four nothing
and now higashiyoka
will hit with velazquez at first two
outs
the 3-2
higashioka powers that deep to left
field fairball it's gone it is god a
two-run bomb
off the bat of kyle higashioka
and the yankees extend their lead to six
nothing
higashioka the home run stroker
and he's getting higgy with it
drilled to left and a diving catch by k
great catch saving a couple of runs by j
cave i want to know the cave
that ball lifted to left and it's got
some carry
gall going back j cave hitting his
second of the year
and the twins are on the board great
diving play to finish off the last half
inning and
as you said the team he came up with
twins got him out of the yankee system
and gave him an opportunity and i
guarantee that feels pretty good they
hit an opposite field home run in
yankee stadium simmons with a sharp
single to center kepler driving a double
to the gap in right center and now
polanco we've got the first twins hit
there's a drive right field headed to
the corner and
that's a fair ball and two runs will
score
i believe that ball landed right on the
chalk right on the foul line
nice job by polanco of staying through
this off-speed pitch
as i said 6-3 looks a lot better than
6-1
and a third hit for polanco
rounding third heading home is simmons
and the twins get a big two-out hit from
who else
jory polanco here's the two one drill to
right field it is high that is far that
is gone oh what a laser an absolute
bullet to right field it's a stantonian
home run giancarlo no sequels to follow
a homers to right and the yankees have a
7-4 lead
and sono unloads to left
and go on a home run
snow hitting his 21st of the year
and it's a two-run ball game got an
off-speed pitch and again looked like he
hit it off the end of the bat
still strong enough to get it over the
wall
mitzutu
went back to it and that's why ball game
seven straight wins for the yankees
as they finish off
this unexpectedly close one with the
twins 7-5 the final
[Music]